I I wanted to reduce myself and my guest
today and I promise you he's gonna do
the bulk of the speaking you don't have
to listen to a Googler drone on for 45
minutes
my name is amici on e and I wanted to
use Antoine I wanted to do the
introduction for one reason I think the
French are very modest and so he's not
going to tell you all the very cool
things that he that Veolia is doing i I
stumbled into Veolia when we were on a
kind of engineering trip to France and
yes we do have an engineering team in
France and this is a very modest company
that ends up doing it's a hundred and
fifty year old water company as I can
describe them and they are doing the
most innovative things that I've ever
seen a company do of anywhere so I
wanted to get these guys on stage to
talk to the story like many of you they
are in multiple clouds and so Anton was
asking is it okay to show the other logo
and so you will see the other logo on
stage but they run a decent cloud too
and so but I wanted Anton to focus on
how they bridge these two worlds and how
they use our security solutions to
really secure the whole thing and so I
just wanted to do the introduction for
Antoine because I think you're gonna
hear a very great speech today a talk
today about all the cool security things
that Veolia is doing so I'll give it to
you at one hey I'm on 20 stacks
I'm the Google cloud product manager at
Veolia and as you have probably heard
and as I mean say I mean I'm French and
so I'm from Paris I'm here to present
you our Veolia is moving to the cloud
and it can be more complex because we
are you will see that we have a not
small company and how we developed new
modern application and now we had two
employees to bring we bring the
employees with us to use this modern
application and model infrastructure so
before talking in details about this
probably most of you don't know what is
virya and as I say Maria is the global
and the worldwide leader in optimize
versus management and I have prepared to
you a quick video to show you what is
your daily job
[Music]
[Music]
let's transform a cargo ship into chairs
wastewater into heat and straw into
electricity these are new solutions for
resource in the world so now you know
what are we doing every day and you also
know that principle and main mission is
very simple was something the world and
by were something the world we say we
wants to limit the impact on the
environment on the different businesses
we are working on so let's talk about
where we come from probably you know
that we are very young because we were
born in 1853 first to supply water in
Paris France after we do the same in
France in Europe and now in worldwide
sometimes in United States ooh after
this we create the energy branch
providing solution for the industry and
just as of this we already have to
celebrate or first centenary and in the
last time in 1986 we create the last
branch it was for the waste treatment
and just some years after this a very
little and younger company you probably
know was created and just in the same
time we create the global name viola as
you may know today we group distrib
different ones so today we are 169
thousand people a 150 country and we are
working on this distri main branch the
water with supplying water 4 million
people the waste by recycling millions
of tons of waste every year and the
energy crops
so by managing solution for the industry
this is very complicated and we have a
lot of things to do so now let's talk
about the IT pots because I think this
is why you are here today and I have
choose to use the same timeline models
to explain how always your story on i.t
but you agree that it's a bit a little
bit showing a younger
and I have just to start to tell you on
2012 because at this time we were like a
big company food on premise we were
having more than 200 messaging systems
and I have choose to give you the
example of friends where we are having
more than 10 data centers we have choose
to create the first biggest program for
employees and it was to migrate all the
user to G suite this is a very big
change and a very new ways of work and
just one years after this program has
begin we were almost 90,000 people on
use on Gmail that was very crazy because
just in one year we were very fast to
move the user on Gmail it was not easy
and I can confirm that because I went on
the in the team in charge of the
migration but it was very amazing
program I have put you some example
about the usage we were having at this
time because you can at the end of this
slide compared with the information of
today and you will see that there is a
huge evolution of the usage of the G's
feed platform after this we create three
main program and I will speak in details
about each programs because they are
still in clothing today and they are
moved to Cloud Data for business and
SATA one just don't forget this 3 name
this is very important so today we are
almost 130,000 people on Gmail and you
can compare the usage of the G Street
platform now or user use naturally G
Street this is normal this is not a
problem and the problem now is when you
say why you don't use these services
because this is the best way to do for
example the usage of the Hangout as a
huge evolution of usage so about today
and to finish this timeline about
tomorrow to know is in the next two
years and we have put some example about
the big points we want to achieve and
they are the migration to Chromebook I
will speak in details about this in one
of the three program developed as I say
modern application web apps by using
Google cloud services be several s and
that as a data center Alice it's very
huge words and this it will have an
impact of for IT so you will understand
why I just want to talk to you about the
club strategy we have and I have made
the choice to choose only five main
point and I hope my boss who is here
will agree that they are not the only
one points but this is very a quick
presentation so I don't need to speak to
you a little more often sorry so I have
choose to speak to you about these five
fun because I think they are very
interesting first is no ops and what we
say we've no ops we say we want to let
or developer like me to focus on the
code and not on managing the
infrastructure we think Google is doing
this very good so why we need to spend
some time on this we'll choose to use
the maximum micro services we can use to
we use again and again these services we
use a cap function we use App Engine we
use a lot of services I will show you
some architecture diagram after this you
will see that is true so no ops of
course means server less because cut
function is the several services and at
the end that mean no data center from
this year we want to have no data center
in France in the name of Veolia and in
the next two years it will be the same
all over the world so by doing this we
use Google Cloud products this mean
secured by design products we want to
seek to have secured by design
application and this is why we choose
appengine will choose bigquery which is
cloud function which are all services
provided by Google and yes as amid say
we have made the first one you have two
different code provider that AWS
and discipline so I have the
authorization to put the logo on this
petition so there is no problem
now about the three program I mentioned
before we want to create a digital
enterprise and create a digital
Enterprise is not as easy as speaking to
you today this three program have a lot
of different detail and I have choose to
only recoup these details in three boxes
the first is the move to cloud program
the move to cloud forum is for the IT
entity for the branch and we want to
help them to move to the cloud for me
the biggest key word of this program is
software as a service first because we
think this is the future
and as I said we don't want to manage
infrastructure we don't want to manage
we don't we just want to focus on the
application and on the customer added
value we can have the second program is
data for business and data for business
for me means that array
because the data is the key of your
application and the last one is SATA
word and for SATA well and I will talk
to this in details after this slide for
me it's collaboration SATA wadis for the
employee and we want to as I say bring
them to a new modern world of
application and you new million ways to
work so in detail SATA word what that
mean SATA ones midsection anytime
anywhere any device and it's very simple
because as you may know when your
company today your employee may want to
work from anytime anywhere and any
devices they don't want to be that won't
it be monetary to work at the office
they want to work from home they offer
they want to walk from where they want
so we proposed a global migration
program to Chromebook we propose to give
a secure and collaborative work place
this is why we have choose to use G
suite for the the messaging system the
second program move to cloud is for the
aunty
áit entity and for the entity - of
course because we want to add them to go
to the cloud we are on a decentralized
company it means before we were on the
model when we say hey this is monetary
this is the new way you need to work
like that and not like that but now we
are not on this way we are on a
selective adoption we are on a way where
we say hey you know you can make an
evolution of your IT you have some offer
like this from afar like that
we can help you we can make this for you
we can give you an advice we can give
you a support it's your choice and this
is not the same way to work and you can
trust me this is a very more better way
to work so this operation can be made on
to step because sometimes you have a
landscape of application very difficult
because company like Julia are older
companies so they have a big legacy of
application so we propose a managed
services on an infrastructure as a
service solution but the final jump to
the cloud for us is as I say the
solution as a service and the platform
as a service if you want you can develop
an application or I should not want you
can buy a solution that is ready to go
how we do that we do that in some steps
I have choose to version them in six
steps but quickly we help them to
discover between how what is the
application they have and what are they
offer they can choose after this we have
them to design a new in a new
architecture of the application we
propose them to add them to build a new
version of this application to transform
this with us or with some Google
partners of course if you want and after
this we we we are going with them to
choose who will be enough to operate if
this is a managed services that will be
maybe a cloud provider like Google or
that can be a sub part company and after
this sometimes we can optimize and
optimize the application for the
user experience or for the price and the
cost of this application so now you know
this true man program we will we will
speak about the the last one this is
that a verb is net but before speaking
about the data I wanted to show you how
we use Google cloud and today we are
almost ready to say that we have more
than 100 application on Google cloud it
kept being a very simple and small
application to a very big and complex
application and I will present to you
some demos of application we have made
and this represent five Android app app
engine services for example and almost
5000 Vickery data set but the testing
point on this is the security but as you
can see on my slide we have 1000 project
and once answers transact you can trust
me is very big you need to secure you
need to monitor you need to check that
everything is OK on your infrastructure
by infrastructure I mean Google Cloud
the platform of course so we have a lot
of aam policy to do that we have a lot
of firewalls we are using a lot of
different services and I will speak in
details about these services at the end
of my presentation but now you know how
we use Google Cloud
let's talk about the data because as I
said the data is the key and we think in
Veolia that having a data Lake is not
that away and you can see some
interesting white paper on Google cloud
website on this and is very close to our
approach and you probably ask me about
why we chose Google crown and why we
created a Tareq and I will answer to you
that where that elect for us is having a
central point of data from weather well
whatever they are to analyze process and
extract an added value of this data and
why we chose Google cloud and it's very
simple because it is very cheap this is
very fast and this is very very easy to
use so how is made or data like in just
four main step
first we acquired the data as I say from
where they were there from application
from was a cloud provider I didn't
mention any any name from user data from
the businesses or from your IOT I have
choose to make just for example but you
can have a very big list of data at this
day use you can see that we have almost
80 different data sources around the
world and after we have acquired this
data we studies without modification on
storage on cloud storage because we
think it's very important to have a
history of each data we will modify
after this step and as you probably know
the storage is very cheaper today on the
cloud so why don't just put the the
storage on cloud storage and have this
if sometimes you need to have a go back
modification list to check this
represent about 50 terabytes of storage
today and after this we make the most
interesting point this is the analyze
and processing part we use the classic
as I say classic pipeline that array
data from TCP
we use cloud pub/sub cloud pub/sub is
notifying data flow we process data flow
every month a lot you can see some some
numbers of the usage we have and with
some data to bigquery this represents
about sixty billions of records and we
are very happy to use bigquery we have a
big team of expert on bigquery and after
this we can choose to export this data
and bring them to external application
web application on Google cloud
on-premise application that has to do is
an example if you want to make some -
Bob because we we use the data to to
make some interesting - bomb wherever
you want because you can open API and
give this data to external application
as I say so to present you a demo of how
we use this data I have choose to put on
to synaptic synaptic is an external
module of the data lag and it will
permits via
to monitor
equipments we have on the treatment
plants for the waste or the water for
example
so it's mean you will wait to see for
example how is the amount of what I have
in my water pump today from now and also
a very interesting point
this application is made on three steps
first is acquired a data from the data
rack and we get an SVG representation of
all the equipment's you will have on the
treatment plants segunda second step is
to prepare this so we merge the data of
the data leg with the SVG representation
to create a final representation we will
present with app engine after this you
can see how this application is this
application is on App Engine and we use
angular framework for the Fontan so the
villages employee can show as I say in
real time what are the equipment's they
have on these treatment plants they be
able to choose which city they want to
monitor in this example we have some
cities in France and some cities in
Germany but that can be very simple or
very complex it depends of the size of
the treatment plants at what they are
doing so you have a lot of information
they are loaded from the data rake every
minute of second it depends what you
need and you can click on an equipment
and have a mod details information what
you have on this equipment and as you
see on my video I have click on an
information and I have an historic of
this data so it's requesting bigquery to
say can you give me the history of this
information from the last month you can
use this data just for your information
and you can use an export of this
information so by a basic front-end
application but a very complex back-end
application so my second example is not
on the same way but it's very
interesting because is an application
his name is clear which permits to
monitor the gas dispersion in the
atmosphere you have provider and makes
by treatment plants
and if you live near a treatment plants
we can be afraid if there is not a
problem today maybe in the industry
sometimes you can have a problem and
this application is here to confirm that
there is not a problem why this
application is very interesting because
they use the boss cloud provider and I
you see that I have made the icon Thank
You Amit first we collect the data by
two-way get the data from the weather
station because they can have some wine
or some rain and we get the data from
local sensor all over the treatment
plants this is under Veolia
responsibility to say if they want to
have a ten of five local sensor but it
depends what you want to monitor
after this we store and we simulate we
generate the panache the panache is the
cloud representation of this this gas
dispersion in the atmosphere we sum this
data to Google Cloud to create with
Google map the representation we will
display on App Engine as I say we use a
lot of App Engine and you can see that
it's confirming this is the demo of this
application in green you see the point
are the local sensor you can find around
the treatment plants you can choose
different type of sensor and different
type of gas and in red you can see in
real-time the representation of this
dispersion this was the first version
and now we round the new version of this
application and the cloud is more
beautiful for the first version it was
not very very the most beautiful weekend
but he has evolved from now you can have
the version of the maps and you can see
if your ohm is at the right maybe you
have recognized your street I don't know
and you have a different type of
information as I said it can be very
technical so you can have also technical
information of about each sensors about
where they are about what the data they
have collected you
mr. vehicle of this data also taking
from bigquery from the data rack and
like synaptic you can use this data to
make an exploit of were using another
application of course these are very
very easy to use application and not
complexity we did not complex sorry too
and to understand how how to use it so
now it's time to speak with Amit about
being copped and after I will be back
here on the scene Thank You Antoine so
so the question you're asking is he's
created all this great data he's created
all these great front ends how does he
make sure that the right people are
accessing this kind of information and
so to do that I thought I could quickly
give you a quick summary of what Beyond
Corp is about ten years ago Google
decided internally that we wanted to get
rid of VPNs we decided there was this
idea that no network was really truly
safe and in fact the way to really
guarantee that every access every
request is actually legitimate is to do
an evaluation of each request and so
from that point all of our we've moved
all of our tools from behind a VPN into
the world we've deployed on the web this
is including things like our code search
where we store our search algorithms and
things like that and the idea should be
that that's false security and every we
should make a request on how everybody's
divided up request looks at that time so
let me walk you through an example of
what that looks like and in our beyond
Corp idea we think of really three
things one is that you the enterprise
need to set policies these are rich
policies that say at a certain height
trust applications these are maybe these
are cafe menus anybody can access it
those are the kinds of rich rules you
have and what does that mean what we're
IPM addressed by coming from what device
what is my device look like what's the
time of day these are the types of
attributes that we want to collect when
somebody's making a request and then
going through and cataloging what are
the applications and data that we have
and making sure they're all protected
and so that with all those three
components constitute what we call
beyond Corp or the beyond core vision
and so let's walk through a typical
example is no revolution revolutionary
stuff here if you look at it at first
blush an employee uses some sort of
device to
make sure that the rules are processed
here that say is this really legitimate
request it's blocked at an enforcement
point in which case in our case we think
of as a proxy and if everything matches
we in fact allowed that end-user to
access the application or the data that
sounds simple enough but a lot of things
can go wrong and do go wrong for people
who try to go at this point
the first one is how do you really
attest that this is actually the
employee who's trying to access the
information right in terms of phished
credentials if you think of their entire
fact that number one attack vector used
to access information it's very easy to
mimic who an employee is second even if
the user is legitimate what is the
device is a device in a compromised
State is it a corporate device is it you
know is it a tablet what is it that's
going on there the next thing you have
to figure out is how do I make sure that
the rules I've applied against my
applications are legitimate are they
over privileged is the network path vet
vulnerable and then you have to collect
all this information together and see
doesn't access the student access
decision be made or not before I have
the access decision is actually allowed
and in each of these we do this on every
request for an application so the
latency has to be near zero in order to
not frustrate your customer right you're
replacing a VPN but if you're putting
something in that's much heavier you in
fact create more headaches very end
users and so what we've decided to do is
attack each of these verticals with
multiple solutions the first one is you
need to have a strong identity provider
and this is not an identity provider
talk so I'm not gonna dive in tab but we
need to attest that this is in fact a
strong user but we want to go one step
further right if you if you talk about
second factor most second factors are
actually fishable credentials
credentials right or bear tokens and so
we need to have a phishing resistant
authentication that we use and we a
Google use the touch key that u2f keys
the device the next thing is on the
device itself right if it's a mobile
device we want strong MDM on the device
if it's a laptop we need to ensure that
the device is actually in a good state
and you can do that in several different
ways and we can talk to those the first
one is around device management you need
to make sure that the your we have a
well configured TLS when you make to the
request that's an obvious attack vector
you did have a very simple rules engine
when you do all this when you put all
this together it needs to be very clear
to it an admin or in a sec ops person am
i building the right thing am i doing
the right thing are these are applied
correctly against the application and
then of course we have the proxy where
the access controls happen and
of course we terminate the TLS and
assuming everything is right there then
of course we allow access to the
applications that could be applications
it can be data but think about this new
cloud world no matter what cloud you use
the the the one of the biggest attack
vectors that are out there these are
public API is right if you want to write
to a storage bucket that is a public API
and so you need to be able to extend
your security boundary around those
api's and so we have solutions that we
were introducing around that space too
and so I thought maybe it makes sense to
talk these briefly before I give it back
to Antoine but the first one that we did
at Google is introduced this idea of an
identity database right it has to have
enriched you you have rich set of
metadata which includes the users the
group memberships job titles offices
where somebody coming in from that's all
par for course I think what the next
thing you need to have is a strong you
need to have strong authentication this
is our primary credentials but these are
also secondary credentials think of the
u2f keys and things like that so you can
actually test that this is the right
user and they need to have short live
sessions a lot of these vendors today
have sessions that go on forever if
you're accessing something that's a
business critical value it clearly makes
sense that you need to have very short
live sessions versus if you're accessing
again the cafe menu those sessions can
live forever the other thing that we've
and we've introduced in just in the last
week is something we call endpoint
verification endpoint verification is
this idea that on the on your device
itself we can take a look at the
security posture of the device is this
as this the users write serial number is
is the OS version up-to-date is the
screen lock enabled is there a disk
encryption on and on and on you can have
the cue can capture simple metrics about
the end users device say yes this is a
safe device this is not a safe device
this is the Corp device this is not a
Corp device before you allow access to
applications and then of course you need
a proxy we at Google have something
called the identity where proxy the
identity where proxy in essence is a
large global scale reverse proxy that
sits in front of all of our
infrastructure and what it does is it
intercepts all of the requests that are
going to an application and makes a
check we said this is a meet this we
services that meets device it's a
corporate device for him and he's coming
in from an IP address that I trust let's
allow access or most of those things
were true but he's coming in from a
public coffee shop maybe we should
upgrade it ask for a second factor here
right and so those are the kinds of
things that are decisions you could
start to make it to proxy layer and then
of course how do you bring this all
together
and you need to have an what we call a
control engine an access control engine
this is where you can start to define
simple rules that say I've classified
all of my applications and to really
really secure okay to leak information
and not secure at all I need to define
what those mean right I need to
understand that if I'm coming in for a
really really secure application it
needs to come in from a trusted IP
address I can set that I can say that in
fact I need to know that it's a
Chromebook that because I trust
Chromebooks more than interest others in
our case yeah so I want to grant access
to that up that device more than I would
for example a Mac or Windows Device and
you can start to see how you would be
able to create these rules they have to
you have thousands and thousands and
thousands of internal applications or at
least we at Google do it I'm sure many
of you have the same card an order of
magnitude you need to be able to find a
scalable way of applying all of these
rules against those applications if you
have to go through and do one by one by
one kind of application of those rules
you'll never get through it and you'll
never actually fully roll out the model
and so you what we actually have done
with our own access control engine that
we're now productizing for users is
create these ideas of simple access
levels right to classify something as
sensitive to access that I need to be
coming in from a specific IP address or
I need to come in from a specific
version of an OS right if something is
mostly trusted ok it's coming in from
yeah that's good enough right I know
that it's a it's a and it's coming in
from a mostly up-to-date OS I'll allow
that access to what we call it mostly
trusted or or if it's it's a end users
tablet that they brought from home and
they want to access that data that's ok
too they can only access a certain
criteria or certain tier of applications
so I wanted to walk through the exact
xual example of what we do at Google and
what we're exposing to end users so
let's take this user this is Joe he's
sitting in his office he's using his Mac
we know the serial number we know the
status of the device he's coming in all
the rules check out is the corporate
device is the right person so he can in
fact access our bug system so the
identity were proxy in our case for this
for global proxy will make that
evaluation and say yep this is he has to
have access to business critical systems
here right where you can see those kinds
of things now let's take a quart of
coral earlier this will seem obvious but
there's resolutions here that we should
talk about right again this is Joe but
now Joe is using his tablet and so the
tab that the rules engine will say well
this is Joe yes it's Joe's tablet I
don't nothing about this device and he's
coming in from a public IP address I
can't allow access at that system right
and so yeah and in this case the
identity watch a new proxy will say nope
denied the access that's an obvious kind
of workflow that we're talking about
here but let's talk about some of the
details here you can start to make this
a richer use case here where you can say
maybe this is Joe maybe this is Joe's
tablet and he's coming from public IP
address but he still needs to do his job
he still needs to be able to access
systems
maybe not the bug tracking system but
definitely his calendaring system yeah
definitely the email system whatever
definitely HR system so you can take the
time off if he needs to we can start to
come back and set rules that say okay
this is Joe and Joe's tablet I don't
know as much about Joe's tablet but if
you prevent presents a legitimate second
factor then we can in fact allow him
access to what we call middle tier
applications like calendaring and other
kinds of systems that's how we at Google
resolved these kinds of problems and
these are the kinds of systems that
we're now exposing with our identity
where proxy and other set of tools for
customers to use so give it back to
Antoine and talk about how Veolia uses
those things so thank you it was very
funny because when we are preparing this
presentation we made the slide on each
side and when we are discussing I mean
say you have the almost the same signs
than me so we say we have the same
problem and the same security concern
this are on four point first is the
identity of show user they update the
personally present to be you need to be
sure that it does if the device is not
compromised and you need to be sure that
that at one spot is good and of course
the application if it is well protected
or not
so how beyond cop and thank you again
Amit and alder Bianca teams for the
helps you provide to give to Veolia how
p.m. cop L pass every day I have choose
to resume a very quick list of the
services we use every day to secure and
monitor or GCP infrastructure first near
the Veolia logo is the cloud security
command center this is a very new
services and I recommend you to test it
because it will be very helpful to have
on every central point all the external
services but of security you can choose
to have and inventory of all your
objects you have on disability
on the first time you see Bianca because
bianca is also a team which is making
some great white paper you can read them
they are very interesting you have also
the cloud resource manager with the
folder the customers the aam rules and
you have a big lot of works to do if you
want to be the most effective company on
the second line you have the GCP billing
because by the billing we think we can
monitor if the usage of the platform are
good or not we can detect some fraud
maybe if on the Monday morning I see a
people which are using a lot of dickory
maybe this is normal because we have a
special Wikus or maybe this is not
normal if the people does not know the
best way to request be crying so the
billing is the key to monitor this
second is the V PC the PC service
control the new services which be with
parents you to money to secure and CIPA
some different services offer project
and let's communicate just the two big
query services of two different project
you have a lot of different way to use
these services but it's very interesting
and very important on the third line you
have cloud AAP and if you have seen my
two application on the diagram we use
AAP on every appengine services we
create sexuality's kenya which related
to app engine it permits you to scan
your application and check if you have
some vulnerability on your code and
after this on the truline you have
another user and employees part with the
security key enforcement with the two
steps the chromebook migration because
migrate to a Chromebook is a little bit
more secure than a laptop i will not
mention a certain operating system the
key management services for the
application to store and secure your
gear key and on the last two point they
are the for me the the two most
interesting because on my job I used
them every day
first is security monkey security monkey
is an open-source project provide by
Netflix and its permit you to monitor
infrastructure from AWS mgcp on just the
same - bomb so it's very helpful if you
don't want to have two different
solution and the last one is falsity and
yesterday I was with the varsity team
and I recommend you to test this because
it's a new security open-source product
sponsored by Google it permits you to
have an inventory of all the objects you
have its permit you to detect some
violation you have on your
infrastructure and to enforce some
policy maybe for example if I think that
I have a port 25 open on any instance I
have on compute engine is a problem I
say when you detect this port is open
just quickly delete this force so you
don't care about the rest so now you
know the different services we use we
have a new project and we are working
today with Bianca teams on this they are
coming in Paris to understand what we
need and we are improving
today and still tomorrow on this part
because now we want to open your
application to our customers but you
know it's very complicate and not easy
to create an identity on the street for
example if you want to let authenticate
your customers you sometimes sometimes
you don't want to have to monitor this
user and of course you don't want to pay
a license for our user which will be
connecting on your application so what I
did
no idea is very simple and I have made a
very interesting example imagine a case
where Veolia is in charge of the water
treatments of Los Angeles I am the mayor
of the city and you work with that I
have a very good promotion so Veolia
give me the URL of the application clear
that I have frozen to you before so I
need to connect on this application to
check if everything is ok unless I'm in
Los Angeles I'm connecting to the URL
aap say stop I'm here to check where who
you are
they bring me to a bottle a very simple
page developed by Veolia where I just
need to say if I'm an eternal people of
earlier if I'm customers on this example
I will say I'm a customer and I'm
rejecting to an IDP provider on this
example I have choose one login but you
can use a different type and list of IDP
provider this IDP provider checked if
I'm existing on database and if yes and
that's the most interesting part of this
example I'm connecting to this new
product of Google Club this name is
cloud identity for customers and
partners maybe it will not the final
name but I am NOT here to make an
announcement but don't forget to follow
this this very new interesting new
project a new product for sorry and this
product is a forward easier so say my
IDP say ok you are present and now I'm
connecting to the cloud identity domain
of the customers of the earlier to
create an identity which will be
connecting the IDP provider to this
domain and now ok you have the
permission to go to this application LP
say ok I'll give you this application if
I was clicked on a I'm an internal
people of earlier I think you probably
know what it will happen I would like to
make this with Veolia domain and I will
instantly connecting to this application
don't forget the cloud identity
customers and partner and I will again
say thank you to the team who is in
charge of this and I know some people of
this team I have today and thank you
amid for this so my last slide is more
furnished lied i and i recommend you to
connect with all the device you have on
this URL resourcing machine that Villa
del come now or tomorrow you can be a
source or two and you can see what type
of different application we can develop
and this is a game
to permit you to be a sorcerer it's on
appengine also of course so what's the
future now the future as I say open your
application to the customer and develop
more and more sexual application on
Google and thank you now see
[Music]